why is the cat destroying my furniture
how do I make sure that my children are
not scratched by the cat the clown your
cat is an idea that people in different
parts of the world have very different
thoughts on in some countries it's a
kind of routine thing to do in some
countries is actually illegal to do in
America it used to be just something
that was done to indoor cats and is now
sort of seen as cruel it's it's
apparently very painful for cats they're
not great at expressing their pain but
it seems like it's an operation that is
a lot more invasive than people
originally thought it shows how we are
trying to navigate this relationship
with these animals which is very new
cats didn't live inside of our houses
full time until about 40 years ago we
had to sort of start managing this
relationship and figuring out why is the
cat destroying my furniture how do I
make sure that my children are not
scratched by the cats you've had to come
up with a lot of different solutions for
people who are having behavioral
problems with their cat than these
scratching behaviors which are very much
part of a half's cat's normal behavioral
repertoire best thing to do is not to
kind of change the cat but to change the
environment make sure that your cat has
a natural scratching post
because even animals like lions have
scratching posts in nature it's just
something that cats do they sharpen
their claws and they even leave messages
on these scratching posts for other cats
that the cat has ways to sort of
exercise its natural behaviors yes I
think you should clip them in normal
circumstances they wouldn't need to be
clipped because they'd be scratching
them all the time but in our home
something that we do provide these
artificial scratching posts sometimes
their nails can get a little bit long I
guess you could say if we do it on a
case-by-case basis your cat's nails seem
to be sort of uncomfortably protruding
or getting all split and dry and brittle
then maybe you'd wanna cut them you know
maybe you have such excellent scratching
furniture in your house that your cat
doesn't need to be clip